well first of all the mission hasn't
failed
yet but the likelihood there's going to
be the taliban overrunning everything
and owning the whole country is highly
unlikely highly unlikely
it happened immediately but it's highly
highly unlikely so the united states
is evacuating afghanistan the united
states uh is pulling out somewhat
rapidly under joe biden this sort of
began under trump but it's it's
continuing under biden
and as the united states leaves the
taliban is just coming back and and
taking over all these cities much faster
actually than
joe biden told us what happened so
actually now the the united states needs
to send 3 000 soldiers back into
afghanistan just to make sure that our
embassy officials and our
remaining soldiers and our translators
aren't slaughtered by the taliban before
they can all get out
afghan government forces
according to the associated press are
collapsing even faster than u.s military
leaders thought possible
the taliban which ruled the country from
1996 until
after the united states invasion after 9
11 has captured three more provincial
capitals wednesday probably that number
is even higher now i haven't checked in
the last hour
uh the 10th and 11th uh cities that the
insurgents have taken in a week-long
sweep that has given them control of
two-thirds of the country which is more
or less what they had before 9 11. joe
biden of course the adult in charge
finally we've got stable leadership he
told us that this was not going to
happen
how serious was the corruption among the
afghanistan government to this mission
failing there
well first of all the mission hasn't
failed
yet
there is uh
in afghanistan
um
and
all parties there's been corruption
the question is
can there be an agreement on unity or
purpose
what is the objective
for example it started off there were
going to be negotiations
between the taliban and the afghan
national security forces
and the afghan government
that
that
didn't come to
didn't come to fruition
so the question now is where do they go
from here
that the jury is still out but the
likelihood there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely highly highly unlikely it's
highly unlikely
it happened immediately but it's highly
highly unlikely oh this will just two
weeks to slow the spread oh hunter biden
didn't lose his laptop to the russians
oh
this that
and the other thing is it any wonder
that these people
have no credibility whatsoever don't
worry though don't worry the united
states has a strategy they know how they
are going to stop the taliban from
overrunning the country and undoing 20
years of whatever we've been trying to
do in afghanistan do you know how
they're going to do it it's not the 3000
troops that's just to get our guys out
of there without them being slaughtered
the way they're going to do it and this
is really i did not expect this strategy
they are going to tweet
at the taliban
taliban known for its twitter presence
they're going to tweet snarky hashtags
and that that oh
you thought 20 years of military action
and occupation was going to do it no no
that the twitter hashtag will quote this
is from the u.s embassy in kabul
escalating taliban violence including
executions of surrendered afghan troops
shows a lack of respect for hashtag
human rights
don't erase afghanistan's human rights
gains of the last 20 years
yeah what are you going to do with that
taliban
yeah what are you going to do with that
huh
you know frankly i wish i wish that we
had known about this in 2001 and 2002. i
guess twitter didn't exist in 2001 and
2002 would have saved us a whole lot of
time and money and treasure and blood
and effort in afghanistan to accomplish
as far as i can tell
absolutely nothing
this is very sad this is very sad
for american servicemen who served in
afghanistan
what
was accomplished
the one thing you could say was
accomplished is that we killed osama bin
laden
but we got him in pakistan we didn't
even get him in afghanistan we got him
many years later but okay let's say
that's it you go you kill osama bin
laden great so
so what are we doing i guess
in a moment of candor if you really if
you got a few drinks in the state
department officials who have been sort
of managing this thing or the pentagon
officials
probably what they would tell you is
we're just treating afghanistan as a
sort of overseas imperial territory and
we're just going to be there and we're
just going to kind of manage it
they probably wouldn't tell you this on
television because i don't think the
american people want an overseas empire
in afghanistan and by the way
afghanistan is known as the graveyard of
empires
but to what end what
what's the point what does victory even
look like the united states has not been
able to define that in
at least a decade at this point
and so now we pull out
having accomplished very very little
because the adults are now in charge
i'm glad you love that clip
i love that clip too you know what
you'll love even more the michael
knowles show podcast which you can get
at apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcast go
there right now
oh good and subscribe and leave a five
star review very much appreciate it
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you